mindset and execution of clouds and
[ __ ] dirt by the [ __ ] clouds and
dirt the number one mistake that people
are making in life today is they're
living life in the middle and I just say
[ __ ] the middle people that watch or
listen to this content are living in the
middle they're hedging and making
excuses and justifying why they are not
100% happy when you understand that you
have to go to the heights of heights and
figure out why are you doing how do you
want to be remembered how does it make
you feel are you trading on a currency
that is greater than money do you have
the ability when you have all the
leverage to have the empathy to give the
other person the upper hand do you
understand
they do are you pulling from opposite
directions got 13 hours 19 hours 24
hours of mentality and execution that it
takes to achieve your goals do your
actions match your ambitions
do you understand the clouds admission
when you're going the reasons why and do
you understand the dirt that creates the
diamonds
[Music]